snakes don't have wings they can't fly
and when you drop most of them out of
window they fall straight down but cries
Oh Polly snakes from Asia are different
the most accomplished can jump from a
window and slither through the air for
tens of meters before making a soft
landing on a nearby tree or the ground
to see where the snakes get their lift
scientists recorded the reptiles as they
wriggled their way down to earth after
jumping out a window
the snakes spread out their ribs their
sausage round shape became much more
triangular to see what this shape change
does researchers use a 3d printer to
make a snake stunt double a rod with the
same domed cross-section but a straight
body instead of a realistic curving one
watching water move over the rod at
various speeds and angles showed that
contrary to intuition the dome shape
could generate much of the lift a
gliding snake needs to glide but the
researchers aren't done the snake's dome
shape doesn't account for all of the
lift the reptile actually achieves there
are forces from the snake's airtime
undulation that may play a role it could
even be that the animals whipping motion
provides some sort of self induced
draught looks like it's back to the
friendly skies for the scientists and
the snakes